et pour en parler nous sommes avec
philippe kalfayan juriste créateur du
barreau de la république d'arménie
bonsoir philippe kalfayan merci d'être
avec nous à vos côtés zahour sadig billy
avocat spécialiste du droit entation
nationale et droit des étrangers bonsoir
monsieur merci d'être avec nous
également on l'a vu un tout un symbole
le sénat français qui a donc décidé de
demander la reconnaissance de la
république du haut karabagh c'est une
victoire pour la communauté arménienne
philippe kalfayan écoutez je suis allée
rival en ce moment mais de toute façon
ce n'est pas c'est un voeu qui est
exprimée je crois ce n'est pas encore la
reconnaissance mais c'est un processus
normal on peut considérer que
l'azerbaïdjan a perdu le droit au
respect de son intégrité territoriale
parce que elle n'a pas respecté les
principes du droit à l'autodétermination
un droit qui est un droit impératif en
droit international
c'est ce qu'on appelle du juste au grain
et et en l'occurrence l'azerbaïdjan 1-1
n'a pas respecté les trois critères qui
aurait pu donc lui donner droit à ce que
on concilie à la fois le droit à
l'autodétermination des arméniens du
karabagh et le droit à l'intégrité
territoriale de l'azerbaïdjan
ces trois critères ont été définis par
la cour suprême du canada quand elle a
eu à à s'exprimer sur la sécession du
québec donc de la fédération canadienne
il ya là trois critères c'est
premièrement le manquement au respect
donc des principes de représentation de
l'ensemble
population donc d'un état le deuxième
critère c'est des violations flagrantes
des droits fondamentaux de l'homme et en
particulier quand il s'agit de menace
sur l'intégrité physique des populations
et enfin le troisième critère il est
bien évident c'est quand il n'y a plus
de possibilité d'avoir un règlement
pacifique
donc de là delà du règlement du conflit
bon laser vesion finalement a fait la
démonstration par elle-même que bah elle
avait perdu son droit à l'intégrité
territoriale
il est tout à fait légitime que les
arméniens aujourd'hui fassent connaître
effectivement cette autodétermination de
manière unilatérale
alors cette résolution sur le haut
karabagh dont on parle c'est est à la
base une proposition de valérie boyer la
sénatrice les républicains étaient
d'ailleurs venus sur notre antenne il y
a un mois pour en parler pour elle il
fallait s'engager je vous propose de
l'écouter des zones tout disait que être
neutre c'est choisir son camp et est ce
que la france est ce que l'europe
peuvent choisir le camp de la barbarie
est ce que la france est ce que l'europe
tolérer qu'il y ait encore haut karabagh
qu'il y ait encore pour les arméniens du
haut-karabakh et d'arménie à nouveau
génocide parce qu'on sait que
malheureusement en plus de tuer des
humains
l'azerbaïdjan et ça ait dépassé toutes
les traces de la présence arménienne qui
est pourtant ancestrale qui date de
plusieurs siècles
valérie boyer qui a des mots très durs
un génocide
l'azerbaïdjan qui essayerait d'effacer
toutes les traces de la présence
arménienne qu'est ce que vous lui
répondez
urs hany baghli écoutez moi je constate
à nouveau qu'il a une hystérie
collective l'hystérie collective
arménienne bon monsieur le préfet yann
il dit qu'il est juriste international
il nous présente décision du coût
suprême du canada il parle de trois
principes
moi si j'avais plus de temps on peut le
balayer tous ces arguments
moi je j'ai attentivement écouté ses
arguments je les ai bien pris un autre
des trois principes il décrit là où
quand je vois que l'azerbaïdjan n'a
violé il faut quand même arrêter est
raconté n'importe quoi
bien sûr on peut parler de l'histoire
vous allez monsieur carayon papale et
beaucoup de choses vous deviez rêvant
mais moi aussi je suis derrière et moi
je suis né à erevan et ma famille de
erevan et tous mes ancêtres habite à
erevan et au début de siècle dernière il
avait 96 % des intérêts en eux que je
peux vous expliquer comment ma famille a
été expulsée et qui sont devenus mes
compatriotes à erévan qui sont étaient
massacrés exclu c'est donc on va pas
encore faire rentrer dans les dix thèmes
et même moi je connais des chiffres et
jaune est des histoires et je connais
217 de mecs compatriotes qui est
assassiné massacre en arménie les 350
milles à 0 qu'ils sont et expulsé de
l'armée mettant pas son nouveau principe
quand vous dites que i les manquements
le droit des personnes
mais attendez les invasions nous verrons
quand droit les âges les arméniens du
haut karabagh il bénéficiait toujours
cette autonomie et d'ailleurs je pense
mon intime conviction que c'était déjà
un très grand compromis au début de
siècle
parce que ce qui se passe au haut
karabagh que des cinq premiers
secrétaires des parties de cinq régions
du karabagh les quatre et arménienne
dont qu'ils bénéficient de subventions
il veut comme les rois le karabagh et
des plus développés que l'azerbaïdjan en
effet certains régions amériques elle ne
faut pas raconter n'importe quoi
donc quand vous dites qu'il avait
maintenant sur l'intégrité physique des
personnes
où donc de droits des personnes ça aussi
je peux pas accepter
on peut rappeler on ne peut vous
rappeler à vous et à vos anciens
dirigeants ceux du cabba et de l'arménie
le crime de génocide de khodjali que
commis par les arméniens
et ça a été documenté avec l'aide de 360
6e régiment d'infanterie mobile russe
qui est du son par l'état russe
parce que la roue s'est dit choqué même
si ça sonne ministre de défense était
avec les origines arméniennes
ça a été choqué les rues sont été choqué
quand le régime en entier à passer du
côté arménien et 26 février 92 300 613
on peut en entendre enfin étaient
massacrés des membres et les femmes les
femmes enceintes éventrées
lll effectué sans broncher sa mission
n'a pas oublié on n'oubliera jamais donc
les conséquences ce qui pèse aujourd'hui
il faut peser ses mots quand valérie
boyer et les autres je pense que je pèse
mes mots indiqué leurs représentants
élus français en digne puisque il allait
ai-je écrit plusieurs fois aux élus
français et au président de la
république quand il a les mots il faut
les choses savoir choisir quand vous
dites ici vos intérêts électoralistes au
dessus des intérêts de la france ils
font peser des monts quand on dit le
génocide
ils font payer vous voyez c'est rond et
on va on va lui donner là c'est un débat
c'est un débat
cher monsieur zemmour jeudi bailly on va
laisser aux répond tout de même philippe
kalfayan qui vous a laissé parler on va
vous redonner la parole après à vous
écouter
d'abord tu français
je ne suis pas dernier rival
deuxièmement je n'ai pas parlé
d'histoire mais je remarque que mon
contradicteur lui est remonté à
l'histoire d'elias longtemps on aurait
pu aller sur ce terrain là et j'aurais
pu dû démontrer que cette époque là ce
territoire n'était pas azerbaïdjanais tu
mets donc et est en fait mon
contradicteur est parti sur l'histoire
ou sur l'adjectif vis-à-vis des élus
français mais il n'a absolument pas
abordé le problème de droit
international il serait bien normal
d'ailleurs de démontrer le contraire de
ce que je viens de
d'exposer voilà donc on ya la
démonstration la du discours du discours
vindicatif violent qui s'est traduit
d'ailleurs dans les faits lors de
l'agression
mais aussi d'une manière générale dans
la glorification de tous les actes
cruels qui sont commis par laser médian
depuis quelques quelques 20 20 ans
pourra pour rappel à la cour européenne
des droits de l'homme à a condamné donc
en 2020 l'azerbaïdjan pour avoir donné
une médaille et glorifier un officier
azéri qui à budapest sur une base donc
de formation de l'otan avait tué dans
son sommeil un arménien à coups de hache
ouais c'est c'est donc la barbarie dont
pas valérie boyer n'est pas une chimère
c'est pas inventé la réserve hadj a été
condamné pour cet acte ignoble lâche
d'ailleurs et vous ne pourrez pas dire
le contraire
et ce n'est pas les armes et à qui le
disent c'est la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme alors en tout cas
l'azerbaïdjan a clairement demandé au
journaliste français de renommée les
noms des villes et villages je cite des
régions libérées de la république
d'azerbaïdjan
je vous propose de regarder ce courrier
de l'ambassade envoyés dans toutes les
rédactions françaises
chers journalistes des médias français
au cours des derniers jours
l' usage des mots incorrecte des villes
des villages et des régions libérées de
la république d azerbaïdjan de
l'occupation par les forces arméniennes
est observée dans les médias français
à cet égard l'ambassade de la république
d azerbaïdjan et en république française
à l'honneur de porter à votre attention
ci dessous le tableau des noms corrects
et vous prie de bien vouloir utiliser
dans vos articles et reportages les noms
corrects selon ce tableau n'est pas tout
seul et reprend je pense que je n'aurai
pas un bon accent la ville de chouchi
devient choucha par exemple la ville de
exor devient latchine en tout plus d'une
dizaine de villes ce sont des des traces
culturelles qui sont effacées on
comprend peut-être la douleur de ces
arméniens amour a dit écoutez moi je
comprends bien sûr le but lors des
personnes qui sont obligées de partir
par exemple de kelbadjar mais il faut
pas oublier que quelle base sur les
tarifs en azerbaïdjan et le gouvernement
azerbaïdjanais il a dit depuis début
août on a rien on n'a aucun grief à
faire aux arméniens civile qui veulent
vivre en azerbaïdjan en effet les
personnes qui sont vécues en azerbaïdjan
sont au citoyen et elle peut vivre et
bénéficier des mêmes droits
mais le problème aujourd'hui et il faut
qu émission khalfa tient aussi compenser
cette c'est cette situation c'est si je
peux me permettre on peut faire un
parallèle avec les séparatismes en
france aucun pays dans le monde
n'acceptera sur son territoire des
personnes séparatistes qui vont prendre
valaisan et par la force des armes vous
détacher d'une partie de votre
territoire
les arméniens duquel bahdja sont occupés
de quelle belle jacques qui n'était pas
leur région ils se sont installés ils
ont pensé que quelle vague va devenir
leur a jamais je reviens à votre
remarque nous ce qu'alpha tiens quand
vous dites de droit international
si vous voulez rester légaliste on va
rester sur l'acte final d'helsinki
1,2175 et que tous les pays on signe en
tout cas 38 au moment de signature de
tous les documents postérieurs et même
le document de communauté des états
indépendants que l'arménie elle même
assignée donc danser tous ces documents
et et tous les autres arguments des arts
mines soit disant que le karabagh a eu
l'indépendance avant de l'azerbaïdjan
les chiffres montrent le contraire les
arts d'agen est devenu indépendant avant
que le haut karabagh ces problèmes et
indépendante
donc vous savez tous ces documents sion
on et balaie d'un revers
il faut rester dans le cadre
international et même la charte des
nations unies
quand vous voulez parler d'auto
détermination je pense que vous vous
vous voulez vous en prendre à l'article
3 4 des charte des nations unies
nous n'oublions pas que charte des
nations unies où l'auto détermination
ils concernent principalement des
peuples sans état ça veut dire des
peuples qu'ils ont pas leur propre état
or les arméniens du haut karabagh ils
peuvent pas bénéficier de cette
situation pousse tout simple et raison
que laure et ta mère c'est l'arménie et
si on revient poule haut karabagh encore
une fois il faut arrêter de dire des
médian et dans l'est dans cette
propagande pro arménien que la halle au
karabagh à être donnés à l'azerbaïdjan
lisait la la la décision de 5g 1921
certes le bureau politique du parti
communiste
certes mais il a marqué l'essai le haut
karabagh dans l'azerbaïdjan et si vous
voulez mais tant l'histoire on peut
aller encore plus loin on peut aller au
traité de curé de chiens de 14 mai 1857
la sécurité du karabagh c'est le crâne
rasé recchi a été rattachée à la russie
et si vous lisez ce texte il est marqué
que le tsar russe le gouvernement russe
a garanti à haut karabagh qu'ils restent
eux khaled l'azéri et d'ailleurs c'est
pour ça que les russes ils vont ils ont
respecté ça si vous êtes à l'elysée les
articles décemment imminente
comprendrait un chat il arrive à la même
conclusion
laroussi finalement avec le recul de 200
ans on voit qu'il a tenu la promesse le
haut karabagh il est resté azéri alors
ce qui se passait par rapport aux
populations civiles puisque vous n'aimez
pas ces thèmes il se passait que les
trans migration massive des arménienne
après traitait de tout match 1 de
gulistan et de corruption a commencé sur
le territoire azéri y compris le tueur
le territoire de ouf ouf et mes ancêtres
et quand on arrive au début du siècle je
veux parler ici du génocide arménien et
je sais que c'est un débat 12 euros et
là et je pense que la turquie a fait un
pas courageux à ouvrir tous les archives
ottomanes
mais un jour le débat prospérera mais ce
qui concerne et j'ai écrit déjà ça ce
qui concerne moi mon peuple ce qui
concerne à laser vaillant que cet échec
qui a eu dans la lenteur leur aurait
interdit se retourner contre nous
puisque les arméniens ils pas il faisait
ce jour de l'entente faire couler
l'empiré ottoman de l'intérieur et
bénisse et de grandes arménien mais
quand c'est l'échec est ce qu'ils ont
fait en panique les autres îlots venue
sur le territoire des anciens kanata
série de demandes arménien et plus loin
jusqu'à bac où ils ont massacré les airs
et partout pour libérer la place 313
milles azéri tué total cinq ans pile à
bas coûts donc là on oublie ça bien sûr
et l'histoire malheureusement avec le
conflit de haut karabagh il sait
répétait je parlais tout à l'heure
d'euros déjà les mêmes aides mais non
seulement de contrôler vous savez ça ne
me sens pas donné mais c'est un débat
c'est un débat on va laisser le mot de
la fin pour philippe
kalfayan oui écoutez je remarque encore
une fois qu on sait qu'ils apportaient
du sujet avec cette fois ci un discours
négationnistes comme d'habitude on est
parti sur génocide des arméniens commis
par la turquie et monsieur pas dans un
discours négationniste qui n'a pas sa
place dans ce débat et ça montre bien ça
montre bien que tout s'est tu
cet exposé est en fait contraire à ce
qu'il veut démontrer en tout état de
cause le droit international est très
clair le droit à l'autodétermination est
un droit qui en théorie je dis bien en
théorie dans les écrits du droit sont un
processus internes aux états et là nous
sommes bien d'accord sauf que quand
justement cet état ne procède pas au
processus démocratique
d'autodétermination des individus eh
bien ces individus ce peuple a le droit
de faire valoir son droit à
l'autodétermination externe
ce qu'on appelle la sécession et j'ai
donné les trois critères qui sont
aujourd'hui prévue par le droit
international pour qu'un peuple mettre
fin à l'oppression à la discrimination
de l'état dans lequel il se trouve
voilà et donc aujourd'hui c'est ça débat
et c'est pas l'histoire que vous êtes en
train de refaire / / / leur à la barre
il ya 100 ans ou du 19e siècle
parce que les historiens pourraient vous
démontrer que c'est une terre ancestrale
arménienne et donc c'est hors sujet
aujourd'hui il ya eu une guerre vous
avez utilisé la force
vous avez gagné la bataille militaire
mais vous avez perdu le droit donc sûr
ce territoire duras d'abord historique
les arméniens ont droit à
l'autodétermination sur ce territoire
et c'est ce qu'ont rappelé les trois
pays médiateurs du groupe de minsk en
disant qu'il fallait discuter maintenant
du statut final du haut karabagh merci à
tous les deux vous merci à tous les deux
fini kalfayan zahour sadig maïly d'avoir
été avec nous pour ce débat